everyone this is kevin from the chester
website comm today we're continuing our
coverage the 2016 World Chess
Championship were in Game three games
one and two were super uneventful two
drawls magnus carlsen and game one
playing the rather interesting pawn to
d4 trump house key opening not a common
opening for him and instead of getting
at karyakin and game two just playing an
uneventful Rui Lopez game so in Game
three expecting something a little bit
different for Magnus Carlsen since he we
only have ten more games all the
preparations going into it I expect
something really nice for Magnus Carlsen
he starts out with pawn to e4 so much
more common to see from Magnus crossing
a little bit more aggressive pawn to e4
pawn to e5 from sort of getting a keen
that Knight to f3 knight c6 Bishop to b5
so getting into the right Lopez and then
Knight to f6 and this is the Birdland
offense that's what we were even
expecting Magnus Carlsen to play in Game
two but we did not see that played more
of the morphia defense with pawn to a6
but Magnus Carlsen is very very familiar
with this playing as the black pieces so
he obviously knows exactly what to do
for the white pieces this is a very
theoretical opening so I expect a lot of
preparation from both sides that really
go into this particular game so
interesting to see how both sides attack
this madness Crossing castling on at the
Kings side probably the more common way
that we see defense against this a
knight takes on e4 so getting into the
open variation could always go for more
of a classical variation with Bishop to
c5 I really like to attack it this way
but Knight to e4 is pretty common
nowadays rook to e1 attacking that comes
back here to d6 and then the knight
taking on e5 now Bishop to e7 is fairly
interesting you know he does have some
options here but decides to go ahead and
Bishop d7 so he can castle on the King
side and then Bishop back here to f1
could always try something with pawn to
a4 if he wants to hold on to that would
be giving up his bishop pair decides not
to go ahead and do that so it brings the
bishop back down here to f1 Knight takes
on e5 and then
recaptures here on e5 and then castle on
the kingside magnus carlsen continues
with pawn to d4 Bishop to f6 and then we
see a pretty interesting move from
magnus carlsen pretty sure everyone in
the room had no clue what was going on
magnus carlsen played rook here to e2
now this is a move that generally if you
you look at you're playing someone you
know just your average player it looks
like a mistake I would I would view it
as a mistake generally speaking if
magnus carlsen makes this move you know
he doesn't really make a ton of mistakes
he's definitely not making a mistake on
a move number 10 in the Berlin defense
it just doesn't happen so a certain guy
cada yakin spent about 25 minutes
looking at this position trying to
figure out why man is Crossin instead of
just coming back here to eat one would
bring it back here to e2 it's blocking
off his light square bishop from getting
involved into the game it's not really
do anything except defending the second
row but that doesn't really help too
much it is blocking his Queen if his
Queen was gonna get involved typically
just protecting the center of the board
doesn't really seem like it's doing too
much now sir karaoke he doesn't have too
many options as far as how he's going to
respond to this specifically he could
play pawn to b6 if he wanted to you know
he could instead just bring his rook
over here to e8 that says I'm not sure
what your works doing but I'll go ahead
and trade off if you really want to but
he took a long time with that and he
played pawn to b6 at the end of it was
interesting after the game they have a
press conference they they ask both of
these players about different positions
different moves and a 1-point magnus
carlsen kind of joked around and he kind
of looked at cardiac and he's like what
do you think of the rook slip-on move
tin and you know kind of got a chuckle
from the crowd obviously not a a slip by
any means it was it was very very much
intended for Magnus Carlsen but if
anything I don't know that this
necessarily the best move for Magnus
Carlsen but psychologically kind of
psyched his opponent out he really
didn't know what to do I thought maybe
Magnus was on a completely different
level playing these moves that he just
had
prepared for and to get 25 minutes off
of your opponent's time bank is always a
good thing now Madison didn't played
rook to e1 and I'm sure cardiac it was
like okay why I just waste 25 minutes
because you almost just wasted a move
bringing back here do you want but all
in all pretty entertaining to see that
turn of events with cardiac and kind of
racking his brain there now work to e8
says let's go ahead and just get rid of
these rooks if people want to I don't
know exactly what you're up to Bishop
here to f4 and then a rook takes down
here at e1 and then the Queen retakes on
a one cardiac two now plays Queen to e7
if you can't look at and say well the
Queen was protecting the pawn white
isn't just taking bishop takes on d4 it
gets pretty tricky so after the bishop
takes here then all of a sudden Bishop
to d6 and then it depends on how cardiac
and wants to respond if he wants go and
take this pawn right here then all of a
sudden Queen to e4 attacking both the
rook and this bishop right here if he
wants to take down here on B to gobble
up this rook all of a sudden the Queen
come up here a8 Bishop down here a1
Bishop to a6 and then at the end of the
day black is gonna go down immaterial
can't really move his Bishop here or the
Queen falls and so he is just going to
end up losing material right here Magnus
Carlsen has two minor pieces to one it's
gonna be a pretty easy in game from here
if he decides not to retake if we come
back here and say let's just go and play
Bishop to b2 then all of a sudden Bishop
to c7 attacking the Queen Queen over
here to f8 Knight - D - after the bishop
takes Queen takes here but then all of a
sudden you see three minor pieces that's
more than material to make up for since
you didn't recapture that Bishop here on
d6 so all in all this is gonna be pretty
bad uncertainty I can t I can it decides
correctly not to go ahead and take that
bishop or that pawn here on d4 and say
decides to play Queen to e7 so say well
go ahead and trade off material if you
want to Knight to c3 just continue
develop from Magnus Carlsen
Bishop to b7 I find him I've even played
Bishop to b7 before Queen to e7
he did play this pawns
to be six for a very specific reason
that's to play bishop to be seven so
even expected this one move before not
too bad though queen takes on e7
recapture and then pawn to a4 Samantha's
Carlsen starting to push a little bit on
the Queen side a6 just securing at the
b5 square for that I've always come here
for a nice little outpost starting to
attack the c7 square which can be very
dangerous attacking the rook here if it
actually were to get there g3 not
covering the square here on h4 in case
the bishop were to come down upon your
g5 so cardiac can starts to get a little
bit aggressive getting his pawns
involved into the game on the Kings side
once your opponent's Queens come off the
board you can be a little bit more
aggressive with your pend you don't have
to have full protection with your pawns
in front of your king so that's kind of
what he's going after Bishop takes on d6
and the bishop recaptures and you may
look at and say well there's there's
double bishop pawns but managed Carlsen
knows that he couldn't go ahead and play
Bishop to g2 and it's no longer gonna
have double bishop hair because the
bishop almost has to take it doesn't
want to lose his rook here so Bishop
takes King takes here on g2 a pawn here
to f5 and then I here to d5 so wants to
be pretty active with his knight he
knows his opponent's Bishop can control
a lot of the board so he wants to make
sure his Knights in the center of the
board which allows them to cover more
ground than if the knight was on just
one side of the board cardiac in King to
f7 now we're gonna start to get the
Kings involved into the game at night
here - III just starting to attack some
of the pawns and then King to f6
protecting the pawn of knights who c4
attacking the bishop bishop comes back
here to FA then the bishop probably is a
little bit stronger in the in games once
there's bishops on all sides of the
board the bishop can just control more
of the board but you'll see magnus
carlsen doing a really good job with his
Knights I put a lot of pressure and just
try to control as many of the palm
structures as possible rook over here to
e1 what's nice - this rook controlling
this long open file you can't just bring
the rook over here to e8 which cardiac
and would like to because there's no way
to defend both this pawn structure right
here and also have a material to recap
here on EA now I played a real cover
here to d8 I think another move
potentially could have looked at was
pawn to d5 just trying to control the
center of the board
maybe Knight to e5 Bishop to d6 really
trying to blow up the center of the
board now I can even play rook over here
to e8 if you wanted to I decided instead
to go and play rook to d8 and then maybe
push forward with d5 a little bit later
pawn to f4 so Magnus Carlsen looking to
blow up the King side structure pawn
takes pawn Dury captures pawn here to b5
after the recapture the knight back here
to e3 attacking the pawn here on f5 pawn
c6 so solid pawn change if you can't
look at this it feels somewhat trollish
not necessarily it's a kind of a game
like 1 in 2 which it didn't even seem
like both sides weren't even trying
except for to get a draw as fast as
possible but it'd be very difficult in
this position to find a win there's just
not tons of material it's since all the
pawns are kind of on the same files they
can easily just get locked up like I
could play pawn to h5 and H for very
easily and there's just kind of a
song-and-dance both sides trying to get
their rooks behind enemy lines but the
other day top level play this looks
somewhat drost now the good thing for
Magnus Carlsen is he just likes to make
some games go extremely long because he
wants to wear down his opponents
Forrest's tamna
he has that no one's better at the
endgame in the entire world than Magnus
Carlsen if there's ever an advantage he
can find it he usually finds it and he
converts that so this is kind of right
up his alley
he understands the pawn structure in the
Birdland offense better than anyone so
at no point like some of the other games
where I was like ok they're about to get
to move 30 and draw I expect the Magnus
Carlsen to try to take this as long as
possible so we continue I plays King to
f3 get started to get his King involved
into the game rook to a8 rook to G 1 and
then rook to a2 now I thought this was a
really good play from certainty Kodiak I
know a lot of people looked at
and if you kind of looked at the meter
depending on where you're you're
watching this this showed a slight
advantage for Madison after the rook
down here to a two I you know madness
craftsman responds with pawn to b3 but
if you can't look at from cardiac in
standpoint he's trying to be aggressive
he is pretty much in a defensive
situation plays rook over here to a8
plays rook down here to a - I mean
besides rook to a2 where is he gonna go
Bishop to h6 potentially you know
putting some pressure on this pawn on f4
maybe but I even like rook to a2 I
probably would have done the same move I
love the fact that he's trying to be as
aggressive as possible and getting your
rook down to the second rank you know I
usually recommend that myself so I don't
think that's necessarily bad you know
but Magnus Carlsen he finds these very
very small places where he can find an
advantage but plays pawn to be three c5
recognizing that okay this this pawn
right here is what the rooks attacking
this night here on e3 is defending it so
he would like to just play his Bishop
down here pinned down the knight to the
route can't really defend this Square
anymore but first he needs to blow up
this pawn so if you could play pawn to
c5 kind of blow up this pawn right here
ideally would be pawn captures Bishop
recaptures this is very good first trick
a caddie I can manage Carlson is not
really gonna let that happen
says hey yeah that bishop you really
want to get involved into the game I'm
gonna go and play rook here to g8 I'm
gonna put you to the test here so King
to f7 now rook back here to g2 but now
after the pawn takes Knight up here to
f5 and attacking this pawn here on d4
and now it's kind of a tough spot
because the King came up here to f7 no
longer was protecting the pawn here on
f5 so this allows you know kind of a
tough spot for serve be a counter yakkin
because he's gonna end up losing
material on board so I plays pawn to a
d3 pawn up here to d3 and then a rook
down here to a-1 so man is Crossin in
that exchange goes up eponymous hero
aren't to get a sense from magnus
carlsen that if there was ever a spot
where he could take a position and turn
it into a win it's definitely gonna be
this spot right here Carlson now plays
Knight to d4 pawn to b4 broke up here to
g5 so his knight on d4 is protecting
this pawn here on b3 and I decided to go
is getting rook involved into the game
behind enemy lines start to really put
pressure on his opponent rook here to be
one that pawns being protected that's
fine rook to f5 check King here to e8
work over here b5 attacking this pawn
upon me is being protected by this
bishop here on f8 so that is a good
thing
rook here to f1 King to e4 rook to e1
I'm inking up here to f5 we can't look
at this Magnus Carlsen doing a job of
defending but he's also just slightly
improving his position with every move
he has his work in a very active
position his knights in the center of
the board which is exactly where you
want it his King is very involved into
the game he's up a Pawnee as a passed
pawn here on the F file he has a huge
advantage right now as we are in the
in-game suit get a cardiac indefinitely
in a tough spot if there's anyone that
can take a winning in game turn it in to
win
it's definitely Magnus Carlsen as we
have talked about before so it's all
about execution from here rook here to
d1 work over here to e5 check King to f7
rook to d5 says hey you can go and take
my pawn I'll take your pawn as well as
we kind of chip away down to the in-game
we can exchange material that's gonna be
fine with me rook takes rook takes here
check King up here to e8 rook back here
to d4 still just protecting the knight
right here so that's good rook here to
h3 rook c5 check and then after the King
moves then broke down here to e2 doing a
nice job of protecting that material
here on h2 Bishop to g7 attacking the
knight Knight to a c6 attacking the pawn
here on b4 first h5 from the rook check
and then work over here to c5 attacking
the knight right here and that appeared
to D H
King moves to g6 Knight to e6 pawn down
here to h5 and if we come back just a
few moves and we look at it you may say
you know why on move 48 why did he not
just take the material on b3 so if you
were to take this material here on b3
then all of a sudden Knight to d8 this
is very very tricky the King can't move
to e6 f6g 6 because the King kind of in
a tough spot so if it comes back rook up
here to e8 Bishop to f8 and the knight
here to e6 that bishops go into fall
minor piece and a major piece against
just your opponent's major piece
definitely going to be a victory for
Magnus Carlsen era so didn't want to
make sure that we we covered that
because some people may have asked about
that question but rook here to h5 and
then just had to go and swing it over
here Knight here to d8 check but now the
king can come here to g6 since the king
is not on f5 Knights to e6 pawn down
here to h5 King to f3 rook here to c3
King up here to h4 or efore Bishop f6
and then rook here to e3 now you may
look at and say why doesn't he just take
material on board he's gonna play pawn
to h4 pawn to h3 at some point though
you would imagine that it's gonna be
better for one of these sides to
actually trade off their rooks here but
if we kind of look at it all depends on
the exact position so if black were to
take material right here okay this gets
pretty tricky the King can take and then
all of a sudden King to f5 and that up
here to c7 the king is still centralized
protecting this pond that's very
important that the King is protecting
this pond right here then this knight
can kind of just move around and put a
lot of pressure on his opponent and
start to gobble up material since he
does have a pawn advantage right here
now we kind of look at this and say
instead of h3 here
why doesn't he just go ahead and take
material okay well if he takes on here
that all of a sudden the pawn recaptures
this is a passed pawn and if he wants to
stop this he's gonna have to move his
King away from that protected pond and
this is kind of a dangerous spot because
then you just have the King come here to
f5 attacking the knight and then if the
knight moves then this pawn is going to
fall just to no longer has kind of that
advantage on boards well it looks like
one of these sides is really gonna want
to exchange Brooks off the board
unfortunately in this position that's
just not what they want to do so rook up
here to e3 pawn to h4 and then pawn to
h3 play continues cardiac in plays rook
here to see one and then Knight up here
to f8 check King to f7 Knight to d7
attacking the bishop King here to e6 oh
hey you can exchange material on board
your Knights pretty valuable so I'll
exchange so that's not too Knight over
here to b6 rook here to d1 pawn up here
to f5 just increasing his advantage a
little bit more King to f7 night down
here to c5 it's a nice little outpost
it's not doing a whole lot but always a
nice outpost that rook up here to a d4
King over here to f3 Bishop down here to
g5 attacking the rook rook here to e4
another one those positions it'd be
great if Carly I can decide to go in
exchange right here he could take with
his king I just have a passed pawn that
he could start pushing up the board
besides that's not gonna be good for him
rook here to d3 King to a g4 I'm gonna
work over here to g3 now this is a
pretty good square it's an outpost
attacking your opponent but
unfortunately I think this is exactly
what madness Carlsen once on board
because he just wants to play King here
to h5 and then you can't take the pawn
here because then you just take your
Bishop let's that's clearly bad instead
of the rook coming here could have maybe
tried something around Bishop to f6 kind
of take it away from the King to take
here maybe rook up here to e6 and then
you play rook to g3 this makes a lot of
sense to me but in the game rook here to
g3 King up here h5 and
the mission comes back to to e7 think
it's a little bit too late night here to
e5 check King to f6 Knight to g4 putting
more pressure on his opponents and then
rook up here e6 rook takes on h3
definitely think that is a mistake
Knight up here to e5 check after the
King moves then all of a sudden the rook
takes here on e7 manage Carlsen
continues to build his advantage
I does have an entire minor piece up on
his opponent so now it's just a matter
of execution from here King to f6 Knight
to a c6
I decided to go ahead and take this
material on board didn't really like the
fact that he gave up material but did
decide to go ahead and do that Knight to
a5 very very odd to move I think on
board to get your knight over on this
one side of the board I think it takes
away from being active on board I don't
think that's exactly what he wants to do
I think that's a huge mistake starts to
allow his opponent to get back into it a
little bit rook to h1 and then kind of
the the questionable move and not only
the game but the tournament so far he
played rook over here to b7
huge mistake he really needed to
continue to be aggressive rook here to
f7 check after the King moves then come
down to F - he needs to actually he's he
should be more concerned about this
second rank this past pollen from his
opponents really the only thing he has
to worry about this Knight over here is
gonna take care of his own business
black can't just take give up this pawn
right here because they don't lose this
pawn structure over here but instead
Magnus Carlsen focuses on this pawn over
here and forgets about this past pawn
huge huge mistake so after the rook
comes over here to b7 rook over here to
a-1 attacking the knight now rook down
here b5 check defending the knight as
well but then this King says hey that's
fine I'm gonna go ahead and start
attacking over here and something's
gonna have to get
if you no longer are gonna have your
massive advantage that you had so Rick
takes on b4 again circa Kodiak cannot
care at all King here to g3 Brooke over
here to g4 doesn't matter at all King
here to f2 night c4 pawn to h3 and
Magnus Carlsen can get a sense that hey
I may have messed up a little bit now I
may have to put all my focus over here
on this past pawn rook over here to h4
King to a g3 rook here to g4 and you see
after this particular move that madness
caution recognizes that he's not going
to be able to have the advantage in this
particular spot they decided to draw the
game so afterwards it was pretty tough
to watch Magnus Carlsen at the press
conference just because he knew he gave
up a win on board he he seemed like he
was gonna be pretty bummed when he saw
the computer and saw the the big airs
that he made especially at the end
knowing that he played so well in the
end game you know took this out it was a
very long game many many many hours
exactly what he wanted to do want to
just where's opponent down and then he
got to a position and was not able to
capitalize so after three games we have
by far our most exciting game both sides
really really went for Magnus Carlsen
played phenomenally I thought Sergei
kata yakkin defended extremely well I
just think this was Magnus Carlsen kind
of at the at the height of you know his
excellence but the very in I'm not sure
if he just got tired or just missed a
position but did miss a win in this end
game so all in all we have three draws
we come back tomorrow certainly a
cardiac can play in the white pieces he
will kind of chalk this up is almost a
victory with the wit or excuse me a draw
as the black pieces knowing that he
could have lost so he's gonna try to
take that momentum and turn that into a
win tomorrow so hopefully you guys
enjoyed a more exciting a Game three and
looked for more in the future but
everyone thanks for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow